2018 is shaping up to be a great year at the
movies.
Big franchises are set to continue with exciting
new installments, while highly anticipated
original films promise to take audiences to
worlds they've never even imagined.
These would-be blockbusters have the potential
to launch a new generation of stars and showcase
incredible performances from established actors.
These are just some of the acting performances
you should look out for in 2018.
Chadwick Boseman—Black Panther
If you were blown away by Chadwick Boseman's
debut as Black Panther in Captain America:
Civil War, get ready to see him step up his
game even further in his 2018 solo debut.
Black Panther will follow Boseman's T'Challa
as he returns to Wakanda to take his rightful
place as king.
It won't be all smooth sailing for T'Challa,
though.
He'll have to face off against a number of
foes, particularly Michael B. Jordan's Erik
Killmonger , a dissident who wants the throne
for himself.
Although we haven't seen them go head to head
yet, all signs point to an epic cat fight.
"Meow."
Helen Mirren—Winchester
A horror movie starring Oscar winner Helen
Mirren?
Sign us up for Winchester: The House That
Ghosts Built.
The film features Mirren as Sarah Winchester,
a real-life heiress who put her entire fortune
into her mansion, now known as the Winchester
Mystery House.
Although Mirren has made horror movies in
the past, Winchester's real-life roots—and
her character's complex, fragile mental state—should
add extra weight to her work.
Seeing an actress of Mirren's caliber taking
on such a multifaceted role sounds like a
recipe for pure terror.
The cast of Annihilation
Natalie Portman leads an excellent cast in
the sci-fi thriller Annihilation, which follows
a group of scientists who head into a mysterious
disaster zone.
The trailers have teased some terrifying creatures
and tense scenarios, and the film's eerie
science fiction elements should elevate it
beyond traditional horror fare.
Joining Portman on her quest are Oscar Isaac,
Jennifer Jason Leigh, and Gina Rodriguez,
who boast an Oscar win, three Oscar nominations,
and five Golden Globe wins between them.
That's a heavyweight cast, but will all that
acting cred be enough to get them past Annihilation's
monsters alive?
Jennifer Lawrence—Red Sparrow
Jennifer Lawrence already has an Oscar and
three more nominations to her name, so every
role she takes spurs anticipation for an impressive
performance.
And with her action thriller Red Sparrow,
Lawrence has taken what could be her most
exciting role to date, a ballerina turned
Russian spy.
As teased in the movie's intense trailer,
she's part of an elite group of assassins
called the Sparrow Squad, who will use whatever
it takes to get the job done.
Although we've mostly seen small, wordless
pieces of Lawrence's performance thus far,
she looks killer in the role.
Storm Reid—A Wrinkle In Time
Madeleine L'Engle's philosophical sci-fi odyssey
A Wrinkle in Time isn't an easy book to bring
to the big screen, and the fact that it's
been so beloved by generations of readers
means there's all the more pressure to get
it right.
One of the biggest pieces of the puzzle was
the film's lead, Meg Murry; luckily, director
Ava DuVernay found just the right person for
the part in Storm Reid.
DuVernay has been very vocal about how impressed
she was with Reid's performance.
Although we don't know much about how DuVernay
will depict Meg's journey on the big screen,
Reid seems poised to cement her rising star
status with an out of this world performance.
"You're kidding."
"Do I look like I'm kidding?"
"A little.."
"I'm not."
The cast of New Mutants
2018's New Mutants adds something very different
to the superhero genre: horror.
Director Josh Boone spearheads the film, which
features a group of young mutants who find
themselves held in a secret facility against
their will, forcing them to battle the dangers
of their powers and the sins of their pasts
to try and escape.
The movie has amassed an impressive cast of
young talent, led by three genre favorites—Split's
Anya Taylor-Joy, Game of Thrones' Maisie Williams,
and Stranger Things' Charlie Heaton.
That's some of the best young talent around,
and it should all add up to a very unique
superhero movie
Tom Hardy—Venom
Many people may have been a bit apprehensive
about Sony's planned universe of Spider-Man
movies that don't feature Spider-Man, but
their fears should have been quieted a bit
when Tom Hardy was announced as the lead for
the first Spidey spinoff, Venom.
The Oscar nominee is set to play main character
Eddie Brock, with the movie rumored to offer
an R-rated, sci-fi horror take on the morally
ambiguous Marvel villain.
"Together again!
We knew it wasn't a delusion."
Hardy isn't the only talented actor attached
to star in Venom—Jenny Slate, Michelle Williams,
and Woody Harrelson are all on board as well,
along with Zombieland director Ruben Fleischer.
Still, the performance of the leading man
will make or break the film, and Hardy seems
like the man for the job.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!